I think with Snow White that the story
is they think it's not going to appeal
to young women because she's kind of
helpless throughout the story like she's
she falls asleep and she's kind of out
of it for half the movie almost I think
they missed the charm because they're
they see this character that's you know
taking care of the dwarves and packing
lunches and like helping them get their
house in order and they feel as though
that makes her seem too domestic and
subservient to these like mythical male
characters uh and I think what they miss
is the pack the fact that she is like a
service oriented person who's very
Charming there's a lot of joy you know
she's constantly singing I think they
miss the things that make Snow White
have the beauty that the witch is
actually jealous of it's not just
physical Beauty it's like Beauty in the
soul and they scrub that because they
feel like those things make her instead
of too subservient it's weirdos it did
do bad the release uh it is still one of
the highest grossing Memorial Day
opening weekends